what up people
it is tuesday november 17th
in the year 2020. two weeks ago
today was election day the very election
that is still not certified and we don't
know what the hell's going on
just think back to what your life was
like two weeks ago today you woke up
that morning you thought oh
it's all gonna end tonight maybe my guy
wins
maybe my guy loses but realistically we
have a solution we'll have
an outcome to this thing and we can all
move on with our lives we can be locked
down again
live in our basement forever and that
would be that
instead everything's chaotic and
psychotic
and here we are it's two weeks later we
got about six
seven states that aren't certified and
there's a lot of wackiness going on so
we're gonna cover a bunch of stuff today
because as i've been saying to you guys
the last couple days at some point here
the trump people
the rubber meets the road you got to
actually show the evidence you can't
just say oh we've got some affidavits
we've got
some rumors about dominion software and
a bunch of that kind of stuff
you got to actually show us something
and it sounds like they are actually
getting
close to showing something uh trump
lawyer sydney powell's been on tv a lot
and she
is making it sound like she's got some
major stuff maybe she doesn't maybe she
does but that
is what it sounds like and rudy giuliani
has been doing the same and he's sort of
heading up
operations on the election side uh for
trump right now so we're gonna go into
that
uh giuliani was on maria bartiromo on
fox business and had
some some interesting hints and this is
a guy who did fight the mafia
in in new york city in the state of new
york and all over new york city and
actually did kind of
kind of beat the mafia before he was
mayor of new york people forget about
that
so we're going to uh we're going to talk
about that obviously the election update
then more lockdowns people
sure the virus more than 99 of people
survive
and uh you know sure they keep telling
us that we've got to do these things and
then these things either work or don't
work but then they just use those
excuses
for for more and more lockdowns uh
michigan has come out with a graphic
because you got to do everything in
graphics these days people are stupid
they can't just read things you need
graphics michigan has a graphic that
we're going to show you
that uh it just none of it makes sense
and then finally the great reset have
you heard about this thing this is sort
of like the globalist plan
to change everything and it's sort of
been lurking in the background and if
you had been talking about it a year ago
people would have said you're alex jones
well now everyone's kind of talking
about it and tucker was talking about it
last night and justin trudeau the
man-child
prime minister of canada he brought up
the great reset and sort of might have
kind of
lifted the curtain a little too much as
to what we're not exactly supposed to
see the peons like me and you
so we're going to play that clip and uh
and talk about that
before we get to any of it guys i want
to talk to you about glint pay i've been
mentioning glint pay to you guys
and don't worry this is not my actual
card this is a mock-up card but i do
have my own card in my wallet so don't
try to zoom in and get me
uh glimpay is really fantastic guys this
operates
as a normal debit card but you can use
actual gold or you can use your
hard-earned cash
you can jump back and forth using the
app and you can pay for a cup of coffee
i used it at starbucks yesterday i
actually
went to starbucks and i got a coffee it
was very fancy
uh as you saw last week i was on amazon
i got a new basketball i got some new
sneakers
and you decide whether you want to pay
in gold
or in cash you can buy gold you can sell
gold
and it's really just an interesting way
of getting some of your finances
sort of locked into perhaps a way that's
a little closer to how you believe
uh things should be done because
obviously we live in some strange times
and if we're going to be paying off
everyone else's
college debt and everything else the
dollar is in a bit of a weird spot
glen card is issued by sutton bank which
is a member of fdic pursuant to license
from mastercard international it's free
to sign up so go to glintpay.com reuben
for more information and to start
purchasing gold today that's
glintpay.com
reuben to get your gold today and now
back to me
all right election time here we go
so rudy giuliani was on maria bartoromo
yesterday on fox news business
and you know as i mentioned to you a
moment ago like we can talk about voting
irregularities you can talk about
you know the observers that couldn't get
close enough you can talk about the
dominion voting systems and all of these
things
and we can talk about it and you can all
we can all look back to election night
again two weeks ago
tonight uh two weeks ago today when
you know trump was ahead in all of these
states and they all stopped counting at
once so all of these red flags are up
there but none of that means that there
was
was widespread fraud that none of that
means that the elections results weren't
right
but they've been hinting at all of this
stuff and i think we're basically at the
point
in the next couple days we're basically
there where
bartoromo has to barnaromo where where
the trump team in effect has to
show the proof right like the proof is
in the pudding guys let's show the proof
so let's throw to this clip uh this is
giuliani on maria bartoromo on fox
business
and then we'll do a little unpacking for
you do you do you need to have that
hardware in your possession
to prove it can you prove the case
without the hardware
or the software we have people
that i can't really disclose that can
describe the hardware
in great detail we have some of the
people
former government employees our
government employees and others
that were there at the creation of
smartmatic they can describe it they can
draw it they can show it
and then we have proof that i can't
disclose yet but i'm i'm confident i'm
confident that
yeah good go ahead and this has to be
examined maria beyond
this election which i believe will get
overturned but beyond this election
this whole thing has to be investigated
as a national security matter
and and the governors who gave uh
contracts to this company
never bothered to do any due diligence i
mean i can't imagine you would give a
contract to a company if you went one
step further and found out
it's really being run by people that are
close to maduro
and chavez i can't imagine you would do
that unless you're out of your mind
so you you only have a few weeks rudy
because they want to certify
the state elections early december do
you believe you will be able to
prosecute and be heard within this time
frame
of course and i can't imagine how a
state legislature can certify
based upon ballots where we had no
opportunity to inspect and it was done
deliberately
okay so there's a bunch of stuff there
and i apologize for our little technical
hiccup everything's under control now
um rudy is basically saying we have
employees we have
insiders who are at smart matec now that
is the company that owns dominion
software those are the voting machines
they're making it sound like they have
people there that were there for the
creation
of it and that we are going to find out
if some untoward if some dishonest stuff
is going on
on top of the fact that he's saying
we've got a bunch of other things
and there's a lot of shady connections
to all this so okay
we're basically there right like
everything sort of feels like it's
whittling into something
and now in the next couple days you you
gotta drop it basically because as
bartoromo points out you know the
election results have to be
uh certified in by i think it's december
13th
uh otherwise then we open up a whole
other uh pandora's box of stuff so
there's a whole series of things
that are going on here as i mentioned
earlier sydney powell who's trump's
lawyer she's been all over tv talking
about major massive fraud
now look i'm not telling you that any of
this stuff is true
i'm really not okay i don't know believe
it or not
i don't know but what i do know is when
when mainstream media
ignores these stories rudy giuliani
say what you want about rudy giuliani as
i said before he was
associate attorney general in new york
fought the mafia
he was no i'm sorry he was associate
attorney general of the united states of
america that was under the reagan
administration but he was also a lawyer
in new york state who fought the mafia
the guy has done a tremendous amount
leading us through 911 everything else
now he's putting his whole reputation on
the line here
if he believes this is legit so the idea
that you're going out there
on television shows and you're saying
we've got the stuff
we've got the stuff well okay then we're
pretty close to
to the drop time sydney powell also
she was i think michael flynn's lawyer
as well so these are people
who have reputations and they're putting
those reputations on the line
if the mainstream media won't cover it i
mean this is another one of those weird
things
where when the mainstream media doesn't
cover something that's usually when i'm
like oh well then something actually
must be going on one of the interesting
things i don't know if you guys are
noticing this
but right now you know this morning
there was this another big tech hearing
and it's just a bunch of bloviation
because nobody's going to do anything
they didn't do anything before the
election they're not going to do
anything now again i like guys like ted
cruz who are grilling the hell out of
jack
but it's like what's the purpose of all
this you guys absolutely aren't doing
anything and we're potentially either
ending entering this lame duck session
with trumple or it's just it's too late
it's too late to make anything happen
but one of the things that i've been
noticing
is when i open my phone now and you see
like you know the latest news or
whatever i try to shut most of the
notifications off
but even on like the twitter stories
they're much less talking about the
election now because they're really
trying to say to you the election is
just over
and i'm seeing more like pop culture
nonsense and a bunch of that
so they're not even giving you the oh
giuliani is saying we got the evidence
stuff they're just they're just trying
to ignore stuff
and as i've been saying for a long time
and i write about dober in this book one
type of fake news
is the stuff that the media won't touch
so anyway look it's tuesday november
17th
two weeks after the election okay we've
had two weeks we still don't have
certified results we've had all these
weird things coming out
they're trying to build a case you know
a lot of people are saying well you got
to drop that info
you ought to drop that info the second
you got it and it's like well they're
actually trying to build a case and as i
said giuliani was a prosecutor
he knows how to build a case so you
don't just keep just dropping little
things right you got to try to go for
the big fish and put the whole case
together
before you present it so i suspect
that's probably what giuliani's
doing here but maybe there's nothing
here and and we're all being played but
i think it's at least worth talking
about right and that's just simply
not what they're going to do and i just
want to add one other thing to this
which is let's
throw up this uh this tweet from nancy
pelosi
this is may of 2017 and what did nancy
pelosi say
in may of 2017 she said and i quote
on the twitter may 16 2017
our election was hijacked there is
no question congress has a duty
to protect our democracy and follow the
facts
she even used the hashtags there so you
know she's serious
protect our democracy follow the facts
now it turns out it was all made up the
election was not hijacked russia did not
install donald trump as president
we went through a sham impeachment all
of the stuff with ukraine it was all
a load of funk but who was undermining
the elections that's the speaker of the
house right
that's the speaker of the house that's
the majority leader right there
telling us as virtually all of the
democrats did
that our election was hacked last time
this time we're not
even allowed to talk about it and if you
do talk about it what are they going to
do people they're going to put you on a
list
i'm pretty sure i'm on the list already
that's that's all right that's all right
um anyway the point is the hypocrisy no
no
knows no bounds and it is getting harder
and harder
that reality war is here it is getting
harder and harder to figure out what is
true because if you're just watching
stuff and they're not even telling you
about it
you can't even you can't even frame what
you're thinking about
correctly and i'll just keep talking
about it and
you know we'll see what happens uh but
before we get
to story number two people what do
millions of americans and three
former u.s presidents have in common
they all agree that bowling branch
sheets are the softest and most
comfortable pure organic cotton sheets
on earth bowling branch cotton is rain
fed rain fed that's real pesticide free
and carries the highest organic
certification that's why it's so soft
because they work with family-owned
mills all over the world to expertly
weave
every set of bowling branch sheets with
the highest level of craftsmanship
craftsmanship it's quality you can feel
the moment you open the box
i love my bowling branch sheets i'm
telling you guys these things are
super super soft and they're cool you
know i'm here in l.a it's warm they're
nice they're cool they're light
they're fluffy and since they sell
directly to you
bowl and brand sheets start at just 160
their thousand dollar quality for a
fraction of the price
plus you can sleep on them for a month
absolutely risk-free
right now you'll get fifty dollars off
any sheet set at bowlingbranch.com with
promo code ruben spelled
c b-o-l-l-a-n-d-b-r-a-n-c-h dot com
promo code ruben for fifty dollars off
your first purchase bowlin branch dot
com promo code ruben
restrictions may apply see
bowlingbranch.com for details
and now back to me all right we've
talked about the election
legally that takes us into covid that's
what you have to talk about next so we
know that these lockdowns are coming
i covered the ridiculous story of gavin
newsom
our wonderful governor here in
california who's going to basically a
thousand dollar
plate dinner up at one of the fanciest
restaurants in all of california with 12
people
indoors but now he he didn't mean to do
it he's sorry but you know you shouldn't
have thanksgiving
with grandma um so we're just seeing the
ever-expanding hypocrisy of our
politicians
who they want certain rules for how you
behave but of course they don't i just
saw a video this morning of dianne
feinstein
in the senate chamber and she's walking
around without a mask
we've got schumer out during the rallies
when they uh
you know after the bite and wind he's
out there without a mask you got
lightfoot in chicago she's out there
without a mask these people
are all ridiculous absolute abject
abject hypocrites you've got gretchen
whitmer
from michigan and we're going to talk
about michigan now who months ago is
telling people that they can't garden
in their own lawns while she's doing
birthday parties
for her husband i mean these people are
absolutely
ridiculous and they should have no power
over all of us
uh or any of us i should say let's throw
to this new image that has comes to us
from michigan this is
the kovid 19 pause to save lives program
so uh here's what they're gonna do we
are open for two
household gathering high precautions
meaning i guess you can have
one set of people who live together in
your home because you've got
one group of people that live in your
home and you can have one other group of
people who live in your home if you had
a third group of people
i guess they can shoot you that's one
thing you can have small
outdoor gatherings 25 people uh now i
don't know where they come up with these
numbers this is
sort of the endless thing so you're
saying okay 20 people's cool 30 people
is in we're just gonna say 25 but we're
supposed to pretend that means anything
uh preschool through eighth grade that's
good to go and that's the local
district's choice they can decide well i
do like local choice i'll give you that
child care is good to go manufacturing
construction and other work that is
impossible
to do remotely so i guess if your job is
impossible to do remotely you can't
spread covert it's incredible so if you
have a hammer
and you need to whack something in you
can't spread cover night having holding
a hammer
and spreading coping those things don't
work together
public transit is fine hair salons
barber shops and other personal services
those will all be fine
gyms and pools for individual exercise
so you can't spot anybody
we're gonna have a lot of people that
are gonna be bench pressing and just
breaking their neck because they're
going to drop the uh
the weights on themselves restaurants
and bars can do outdoor dining takeout
or delivery so you can't even social
distance if you if you take a restaurant
at 33
capacity at a third capacity basically
we're not even going to allow you to do
that anymore so we're going to destroy
all the restaurants
professional sports are allowed without
spectators
so professional sports so that's good
the professional athletes can still make
all their money
apparently amateur sports or school
sports no no no we're not going to allow
that
i guess professional athletes are more
immune to covid that makes sense
parks and outdoor recreation are okay
but does that include
playing a sporting event at a park can
you do that not sure about that uh
funerals we're going to cap them at 25
people
which that makes no sense to me because
you're already at the funeral home
so it's like if you're going to kill a
couple people i mean now we're saving
costs because it's like all right we get
30 people there five of them drop dead
you can just start burying people right
then and there i get it the funeral home
is not the cemetery but you know they
have some people there that could
facilitate the whole thing happening
uh and then of course health care
services that'll be fine now here are
the things that are not
open okay not open high schools for
in-person
learning right because we're just going
to sit all the kids at zoom where they
nobody can see anybody they can put up
fake avatars and we're going to pretend
that they're learning okay it's just
a load of bunk and nonsense also please
people
show me the numbers are high school kids
spreading
cobid to each other and getting sick in
obscenely high numbers and that thus
killing people or are we actually
destroying our ability to teach young
people like
since it's the latter colleges and
universities in-person learning no no no
no
not going to do it not going to do it
work places where work can be done from
home so that again if you have a hammer
you're good to go
but if you're just some peon at an
office you're screwed stay home forever
in your basement restaurants and bars
they are not open again it's
just the indoor dining thing organized
sports except professional sports so i
got my answer
to the earlier question organized sports
except professional sports so that means
if you're a professional basketball
player i know the nba season's done but
they'd let you play on a court
and you're good to go but 10 kids
even if you you know did a temperature
check on all of them
and said okay you kids can get out there
you're all healthy you
you can play basketball now they're not
allowed to do it that makes sense so
let's just keep them home all day right
like let's just keep them
in the dark and on their computers all
day long that seems better
theaters movie theaters stadiums and
arenas are all closed goes without
saying
bowling centers i call them a bowling
alley they call them bowling centers
ice skating rinks and indoor water parks
that's
it none of those are going to be
happening
bingo halls casinos and arcades who
wrote this
all of your local bingo halls are closed
people i do enjoy bingo but it's just
kind of funny that the bengal halls
are closed uh casinos and arcades
so you know if you've been waiting
around for the you know the new miss
pac-man
you're screwed people uh and finally
group fitness classes
also so it's like get a peloton or
you know you're screwed okay peloton
time
because you can't go to the gym anyway
every day we see more and more of this
stuff and i am not sitting here as i've
said to you guys a million times i'm not
sitting here
as someone that is denying that covet is
real
but why are we trusting these people at
this point they get everything wrong
two weeks to flatten the curve months go
by now they want more restrictions
gavin newsom here in california was was
looking at a study from saudi arabia
to see what curfews might do for us
because i guess if you can just lock us
all home at 10
that somehow stops the spread and i'm
glad they're getting that information
from saudi arabia it's like we we are
really dealing with something that is
unprecedented and i
and i think well we all know that right
we all know that
we're dealing with something
unprecedented but it's like how far
can they push us can they say we are
literally going to monitor
how many people you have in your house
how many families quite literally how
many
families of people you have in your
house you know this is
this is the time of year rolling into
thanksgiving
and into christmas this is the time when
we're supposed to give thanks
we're supposed to be appreciative we're
supposed to be around family you know
one of the things that social media did
it was supposed to make us social but in
many ways it made us
more anti-social and it locked us on our
phones and kept us away from people and
started making us
hate people instead of love people more
if there was ever a time in the world i
mean really if there was ever a time in
your life where we needed a thanksgiving
doesn't it kind of feel like this is the
year to do it like this is the year
where you should
sit around a table with some family
members and some friends
and maybe you agree with them on some
stuff and maybe you disagree with them
on some stuff and maybe you talk
politics but
believe it or not maybe you don't talk
politics but like we actually get to
break bread with with human beings and
say boy we're really thankful to be
here in america or you know if you if
you celebrate it
in another country you know just that
that we're thankful for freedom and all
of that stuff like was there is there
ever a year in your life that maybe it
was more important than this year not in
my life i was born in 76
been a long time okay i'm no spring
chicken over here
so you see my point guys that they're
they're taking away all of the things
that tie us
together and then they're just keeping
us online all the time and then and then
eventually they'll just start censoring
the hell out of us online
and we won't even know what it'll be
like to see to see another person
but if we had if we had true
public servants that actually cared
about us then they would be out there
every day
saying these are the reasons we're doing
these things because when we did lock
down we saw the rate go from this to
this
and then we let it out and you know we
opened up and then we saw this happen
but they don't tell you any of this
stuff they just keep pushing and pushing
and pushing
and and by the way i don't think that's
some grand conspiracy i think this is
sort of what
power is i mean this at a at a sort of
high level
like power once it starts getting power
it just starts spreading and growing and
morphing right and then it's just
it just takes everything and good people
just sit there
and they're like oh you know i wanted to
have thanksgiving with the family but
you know half the family won't show up
because they're afraid because they
watch cnn all the time
and it it ain't good people we got to
figure out how to deal with this thing
um but this is a perfect segue
into into the third story that i want to
talk about because
uh this this great reset
uh phrase has been being bounced around
on twitter a lot it's not something
you're gonna hear about
uh in in the mainstream news at least
yet
you won't hear about it until they've
accomplished all of their goals
uh but justin trudeau was being
interviewed and he talked about the
great reset in relation to covit and
lockdowns
and just sort of everything that's
happening economically
and every other way so let's take a look
at the clip this pandemic has provided
an opportunity
for a reset this is our chance to
accelerate our pre-pandemic efforts
to reimagine economic systems that
actually address
global challenges like extreme poverty
inequality
and climate change um
did he catch that no obviously there's a
lot more to it but this is a time
because of coba to accelerate our
pre-pandemic
plans to change our economic systems
did we have those plans free pandemic
does anyone remember
us all and what he says when he says we
he means the world
he doesn't mean canada specifically yeah
it'll happen in canada under that
buffoon
but what they're talking about is to
literally up
end the world systems and he's telling
you yeah
we're using covet as the excuse so when
i tell you that they want just these
endless lockdowns and just to keep
ascertain
accumulating power and the rest of it
it's like this is not made-up stuff and
in a weird way we all
feel like conspiracy theorists but but
you're only you're only not a conspiracy
theorist
if if you're blind in a way right like
i'm not saying all like they're just
coming but like there's this group of
ten people and they're sitting there and
they're smoking and they're discussing
all this stuff but
but they kind of are at the same time
this this is really nutty stuff
i mean think about what he said
accelerate our pre-pandemic
plan to change economic systems
so they're telling you we are using
covid
to severely alter how the world will be
after kovid and then when we install
chuck schumer's words when we install
joe biden as president this guy with
dementia who's just going to bring in
all of these plans and again we're
already bringing critical race theory
back title nine
we're gonna he ju joe biden they just
announced they're gonna have like a a
systemic
they're hiring like a group of systemic
racist
experts that really sounds like a thing
systemic racism experts like
yeah they're experts in racism and they
are going to put it in the system that's
what they're going to do
there's something weird going on here
but anyway i didn't want to do too much
on this story because i want you to
google it
and do a little research for yourself
and we'll talk more about it over the
next couple days and probably the next
couple weeks and perhaps we'll be living
under this
new authoritarian regime soon enough and
then we won't be able to talk about it
but i want you to google the great reset
do a little research world economic
forum
see what you think see what you think
and and listen to what they say
that's the point like he's kind of
telling you hey we had plans to make
something
go down and now we got a great
opportunity because of covid like
lori lori all right people i got a jump
i got a few meetings today and a bunch
of interesting things happening which uh
i sort of referenced yesterday but
there's some good things happening
that i'll hopefully be able to share
with you guys in the next little bit
world's a little nutty but
but don't you go nutty it's gonna be all
right more tomorrow
see ya
you